Is it normal that I could barely see any light coming from the plasma ball?
So if you're ready the true right
There's at higher frequencies. It's really hard to see the light
Well the true right the small the new smaller ball. So everybody's got different equipment here
So some people that have the true right with the larger ball
It was often much more difficult to see the light because it's dispersed through that
So that was an issue people that are running the Atelier Robin if
You're programmable running 11th harmonic frequencies
They are really difficult to see the light through that ball
Typically people that are running the true right with the small the shorter ball, which is considered true
Rice newer bulb. It doesn't have as much gas in it and it will
It will light brighter
typically
so
the larger
I think better bulbs the earlier true right bulbs and the current
bulbs that we created for the Atelier Robin
And especially if you're running higher frequencies or even more especially if you're running the
All out of the harmonic frequencies you could hardly see the light
I mean you might square during a daylight time. There's no light coming out of this ball
Especially the crystal bulbs. You can't see it. You'd have to literally put it in a dark room to see the light coming out of it
And it was intentional. So
I mean one of the biggest complaints that we had over the years is that the light would keep them up
We don't want so much light. Still getting the frequencies through the light
Carried out of photon
But it's not as bright
Because the new the new bulbs that we have are are the
The old gas combination as well, which aren't going to light as bright. So it's a little more expensive gas combination
which
So how much technical physics things with that, but it could be more beneficial. So
Yes, the answer is it's normal that you can barely see any light especially at higher frequencies
Especially if you're ready to let the tow bike